let's take you straight across to
Thailand because we have some good news
to bring you all 12 boys and their coach
have been brought out of the cave live
according to Thai Navy SEALs or
correspondent Sally Lockwood is there
for us they did a lot quicker than
initially said they were didn't he is it
Jane and it's the news we've been
waiting to bring you it's the news the
world has been waiting to hear and been
willing it seems the world has been
watching this story and willing these 12
young boys and their football coach a
safe rescue and we can now happily
report that that is indeed the case it
seems that a near miracle has been
performed here over the last three days
after we were told when they were found
on Monday that the options were far from
great rescuing them under water had
immense dangers huge risks but it became
the only option on the table in terms of
getting them out quickly because of this
monsoon weather but they're experiencing
at the moment in Thailand so the risks
were high there was huge tension here a
lot of apprehension about this mission
but the Thai Navy SEALs along with
international divers and we understand
where divers have been hugely important
in this rescue process they've done it
and it's complete testament to the their
skills and talent the trust that they
want from these twelve boys and their
coach but also the strength of these 12
young footballers that they have spent
the last war spent 17 nights on a Ledge
in a flooded cave in darkness very poor
nutrition and they've done it they've
managed to swim one of the toughest
dives on the planet with no diving
experience and as very weak swimmers but
we are delighted to report that they are
all safely out they've defied the odds
and if they follow the pattern of their
eight friends who were rescued over the
last two days they should we hope also
be in good health and in good spirits we
will bring you more on their condition
as we find out
and they're all being taken to hospital
as you say where the others have been
taken some suffering with lung
infections they're concerned that they
may have been bitten by bats in the cave
but but you know they're all alive which
is is something that their families you
know in the days after their their loss
just must have thought would never
happen
yeah it's astonishing isn't it the most
serious condition that we've heard of so
far is a suspected lung disease which is
hardly surprising after more than two
weeks in damp cold and examp cold
environment but we understand that on
the whole they are showing signs of
being fairly strong and fairly resilient
and in fact medics have put it down to
the fact that they are football is that
they've coped so well that they were
obviously healthy boys and perhaps the
camaraderie of all being together has
helped as well but the four boys who
were arrested who were rescued in the
initial group two days ago on day one of
this rescue
they are already up and about walking a
bit around their beds eating soft food
before who were rescued yesterday we're
not sure they're quite at that stage yet
but we understand all eight of them have
been given a treat the treat they
requested was chocolate spread on bread
frankly I think they can have whatever
they want at the moment but it does
sound like they won't be seeing their
families until test results come back to
show that they don't have any serious
signs of infection of course there are
various side effects to spending more
than two weeks in a cave nine days with
no nutrition and of course wondering
whether the world would ever find you
thankfully they were found on Monday by
two British divers incredible footage of
them smiling and looking in fairly good
spirits they've had a medic and at three
or four tiny Navy SEALs with them
full-time ever since and in that time
they've been given gels to get the
nutrition back up they've also been
given crash courses in diving and
swimming it's fair to say these boys
have surpassed every expectation and
they've carried out this extraordinary
rescue with the Thai Navy SEALs and
come out and hopefully we will hear news
of them very soon and they'll be
reunited with their families in the next
few days they'll be able to see their
families through glass but they won't be
able to see them in person until they've
been fully checked and cleared of any
serious infection but very good news
from Chiang Rai province Jane